- So, your baking show Nailed It!,
it was nominated for an Emmy, right?
- Yes, yes, yes!
(applause)
Thank you.
We did lose.
We lost to RuPaul's Drag Race,
which I get it, it's my favorite show.
I truly love it.
- It's hilarious.
- [Nicole] It's so good.
- Yeah, did you get to meet anybody cool?
Have you ever been to the Emmys before?
- No, I've never been to the Emmys.
- Yeah, I've only been
once and I felt like
which one of these is not like the other?
- [Nicole] Only one time?
- Why the hell would I be at the Emmys?
- Because you're all of our American idol.
- Well, no, I just mean like
I mean, now I have a TV show,
but before you know, singers
don't generally show up.
- Oh, I guess so.
Well, it was my first Emmys.
It was very glamorous.
I loved it.
There was just famous
people very close to you
which is like a real delight.
- Yeah.
Well, when they're a delight.
- Well yes, but they're all
well, they're walking
around with publicists
so they can't have,
they don't have time to be mean, you know.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I saw Viola Davis
and I love Viola Davis.
- Me too.
- I also saw her on a plane recently
and I was like I need to talk to her,
but then I was like she's living her life,
don't do it, so
(laughing)
I didn't do it,
but then at the Emmys I was
like this is a work event,
I can talk to whoever I want.
(laughing)
- [Kelly] It is a work event.
- I just picture two
people on your shoulders
just talking to you.
(laughing)
- Good cop, bad cop.
- So, I went up to her and I
was like I am bothering you,
but I need you to know I love you.
And she truly was like
half eating a hamburger
and was like mm hmm.
(laughing)